rodeado por unas de las brigadas que ha
venido de Francia a echar una mano este
bombero de Quebec da las últimas
explicaciones
esos bomberos vienen del sur de Francia
para el jefe de operaciones del
destacamento esta formación previa es
esencial debido a las condiciones
locales específicas Empezando por la
extrema densidad del bosque quebecen con
pocas carreteras de acceso Pero eso no
es todo el otro
la otra especificidad es que no hay
puntos de agua no tenemos una reserva de
cisternas como en el sur de Francia así
que tenemos que adaptarnos a la multitud
de ríos de la zona
Canadá lleva varias semanas sumida en
incendios forestales históricos en el
oeste del país en la Columbia británica
y en la provincia de Alberta tras unos
días de tregua los incendios se
intensificaron de nuevo el viernes
provocando la evacuación de varios miles
de personas el sábado en Quebec mientras
que los incendios en el noreste es la
provincia se consideran estabilizados la
situación en el Noroeste sigue siendo
difícil cerca de 14.000 personas siguen
bajo orden de evacuación en la región
con la formación llegando a su final la
ayuda de los bomberos franceses
inminente en todo el país las
autoridades contabilizaron el sábado 416
incendios activos 203 de ellos fuera de
control con más de 4 millones y medio de
hectáreas quemadas desde principios de
año